so how are you
feeling I mean I'm just like really
excited I was on season 1 USA of Lev
viand was the first bombshell with that
too and it was filmed in Fiji so for me
it's just genuinely like this full
circle moment of coming back four years
later like felt like a little girl and
now I'm like I'm a woman and I'm back
let's go you know I love that I love
that what what lessons did you learn
from your first love Island Experience
and how how will that help you what kind
what did you learn and how will that
help you in this next one I mean I feel
like I learned on my season and I got a
pretty good response just in the way
that I was very true to myself so even
though you're on TV like cameras are
around there's this group of people that
you've never met it's I think it's very
hard to do that at times but for the
most part by doing that I was able to
make like genuine connections and
genuine friendships and once I left like
the same person I was there was the same
person I was inside so my first time
going in I felt like I was 21 years old
and it was just I think really hard cuz
I was more antisocial I never had a
boyfriend before and I felt like it was
just really hard at times for me to
fully be able to be myself like I think
I did a pretty good job of being
authentic and true to myself which is
why I think I was able to make really
good auth authentic like connections and
stuff but yeah I think that was just the
biggest lesson is going in this time
even more knowing okay I'm in the game
for me I'm in the game to be myself and
if like the people in there don't Vibe
with that or I don't find an actual
connection like that's okay I just need
to be me because I feel like a lot of
people sometimes get in and they're not
fully themselves and then they kind of
have a hard time finding their place in
the Villa so this time going and I was
like they're going to get all the here
not a piece of her not a little bit 10%
like all of her you know absolutely and
that's that's important cuz like you
said you can really tell like and the
audience can tell too so I love that
you're coming in like full force mature
you know better than ever and ready to
tackle it I love that little bit of the
still crazy cure in there but you know
yeah a little bit more mature this time
we got we got got mix it
up absolutely absolutely so you're for
you're in love Island games right what
is more important for you love or
winning for me 100% it would be cool to
say winning I'm a bombass type
but like I genuinely am an
emotional Pisces romantic at heart so
going into it for sure once again I'm
going for love mostly of course I want
to win and kick ass but I got my first
boyfriend off the off of the show the
first time and we were together for
almost half a year and met each other's
families and it was like this beautiful
situation where I learned about myself
had this really great relationship that
I learned a lot in you know as well so
going into going into this no matter
what I was like I'm going to be open to
a true connection and really be myself
and go for it yeah okay so you came into
the house as the bombshell or the Villa
excuse me as the bombshell and you got
to choose your partner and you chose
Miss
Megan I want to know okay outside from
the obvious what Drew you to
her I mean for me going in as well this
time love Island usually is Guy girl
recouplings and I've been very open
about my sexuality on my Platforms in my
life in general since the show before
the show so this time going in I really
wanted to be true to myself whether
whether I wanted to couple up with a guy
or a girl you know I was going to choose
what I wanted and not what the norm or
the typical was and just go for the
person that I like the most and
thankfully when I walked in I mean Megan
is drop dead gorgeous I'm sure we all
fre freaking know that and then to also
talk to her and to realize that she's a
lot like me in the ways that she's very
true to herself like she's not afraid to
say how she feels she's very much so
like this calm but confident energy that
I was really attracted to so to be able
to have a lot of stuff in common you
know when we're having these chats to be
attracted to someone but also to be like
okay we're very like and we randomly I
found out have the same birthday like we
are almost the same human being which is
kind of like you don't want to date
yourself but yes we had we have a lot of
things in common so it was really just
good and I had to follow my gut and go
for it you know being the only two girls
coupled up not sure how that's going to
work out for the challenges and what
we're going to be expected to do but you
know I didn't care my Forefront want was
to find someone that I had a romantic
connection with I love that too and I
love what you're doing I mean I know you
just went with your gut in your heart
but what you're doing is so important I
think for all the folks out there like
you who uh you know like both and like
whatever they want to like and seeing it
on love Island which has been so binary
is so so great to see so I am so
grateful to you for that just in and of
itself
and thank you hey I mean like I said
this time going around and because I
came out on my first season I mean I was
already out but I was open about it on
the show it it did I see like saw help a
lot of people and I had people on social
media you know dming me and coming out
to me before they felt safe to do it
maybe with the people around them and it
just was like okay it really does go a
long way to be true to yourself and I I
think it's so important you know so
thank you for saying that I
wholeheartedly agree I wholeheartedly
agree so um well you kind of touched on
this but I wanted to ask you know I know
you chose Megan because of all of those
other reasons but was there also any
strategy involved you know like I said I
would love to be this Mastermind and be
like yes of course course there was but
no and I mean being in the Villa that
first day and talking to people you know
you go in you're thinking love Island I
I knew it was a different spin-off type
thing but at the same time I'm like okay
it's going to be like fun little games
but love is the Forefront and very
quickly I was like oh no people are
thinking in a different way or coming
onto this and not even really needing to
be looking for a partner in that way
they could be looking for an athletic
partner that they think is going to do
really well at the game so very quickly
I was like oh this could be a little
different than what I think but I still
have to do what I want to do and the
Forefront for me going in was to find
someone
as no it's great it's great you know we
believe in love we believe in love yeah
and I do think that girls are smarter
than boys I'm like that's my I mean
listen I don't know when it comes to
maybe lifting heavy but I do think
two women working together can go very
far and do very well compared to maybe
some of the guys in the Villa so I think
we're
good I love it I love it and um is there
anybody else you have your eye on or is
Megan like it I wouldn't be surprised if
she was it but I am curious yeah I mean
obviously I talked to Curtis a decent
amount I he's like my normal guy type of
just he's kind of goofy slight dad body
like love that you know but like he's
definitely some and we have a lot of
like the Arts and Music we have that in
common so he was someone going in that I
was like okay when I saw him I I was
familiar with him and I was like okay we
might have a lot of stuff in common he
actually reminded me of the guy casual
that I partnered up with on my first
season of of L Island and then yeah he
was really the only other person I was
like maybe you know but we'll see
because as far as people know from my
season I don't always just go like I I'm
risky I I want to try everything to find
the best connection to find the best
person so so I'm never just yeah one per
like that sounds so shitty but it's soon
it's very soon you know no I that's
important I live for that like keep it
real right yeah yeah like you know you
date someone for a couple days and then
sometimes you're like oh or sometimes
you're like wait this is this is it so
I'm just always the type of person that
I'll always be treating myself and yeah
you gotta love Island you got to take
risks absolutely um so are you worried
about Callum at all cuz he's very very
into your lady right now yeah so I mean
I talked to Calvin and the boy he's
hilarious but as far as like competition
in that way I'm sorry I do not see
competition he's a cute guy and and
let's go battle on you know
but if we're being honest no I I'm not
like oh Callum I'm scared like you're
cute but to me as far as what I go for
and if Megan's anything like me you get
you can have a pretty face but there's
got to be something behind it and I love
K's personality but romantically I'm not
sure if he's looking for that on the
show so Megan's being true with me as
far as that's what she's looking for I
don't on on the real think that there's
like I'm not I'm not
scared okay good deal yeah I do feel
like you and Megan are on the same page
with that about what you want and also
about Callum CU he is he does like to
play the field so he does you know he's
hilarious
like it's been so entertaining watching
him I'm like you're
funny and such a fast talker too oh my
God I couldn't understand anything he
was saying the whole time I was like
what like he was the hardest one out of
the whole house for me I had no clue oh
wow well I I'm looking forward to seeing
more of y'all's interactions and um one
last question is there anybody in the
house that you feel is operating purely
on comp competition only and isn't
really looking for
love I mean I think for me coming in at
this point it's too soon to really know
everyone's being very friendly very nice
which that could always be a tactic I've
done other shows which are even more
challenge based and that's a big thing
is be liked by everyone so coming in
everyone was so welcoming that sometimes
you almost have to be like who's really
being nice to me and who's trying to
make allies or who's trying to do this
like you don't know people's true
intention so I think over maybe a couple
more days which things move so fast you
know in there that I'll get more of an
understanding but as of now everyone is
kind of still I think playing both sides
of it you know if that makes any sense
so we'll just have to wait and see yeah
absolutely keep an eye out for those
mind games too exactly but yeah but I'm
pretty good at clocking when people are
being shady so I like it won't take me
long but we'll we'll see as the season
goes on awesome I love it thank you Kira
we had some tech techical difficulties
but we got through it um appr we did the
damn thing all right and I appreciate
you I appreciate your energy I'm so
excited to watch your journey on the
love Island games and your relationship
with Megan I'm very team Kira and Megan
I'm I'll get it on a t-shirt I'm
ready I I'm rooting for y'all absolutely
love it oh thank you thank you
for taking the time to talk to me as
well